und der typ der einfach seine waffe viel
zu oft so kleine mädchen und so was
alles als viel zu wichtig weil diese
nicht akkurat in der kamera doch
wirklich wirklich ich habe davon kein
foto aber das war so krass das war ich
ich ich würde auf alles was ich besitze
hallöchen liebe freunde und herzlich
willkommen zurück zur weiteren folge
captain kräften kam haye für euch ist es
zwar noch ein tag für uns ist allerdings
eine woche und ich weiß doch dafür unten
warm und ein riesiges chaos mit den
ganzen mops hatten und viele explosionen
und alles möglich und ich hab mich
darunter eingebaut
aber wir müssen mal wieder so ein
bisschen fahrt aufnehmen und uns wieder
mal den erfolgen wird und wir haben auch
ein paar zuschauer fragen gelesen bzw
nicht zuschauer fragen sondern zuschauer
kommentare von euch da war unter anderem
dabei dass er meinte wir sollten ein
text wegnehmen das lohnt sich allerdings
nicht da wir in der version 14 w 25 b
spielen und wir wissen nicht wie viele
neue blöcke jetzt hinzugefügt würden wir
kennen zum beispiel hirschen diese neuen
grünheid sachen beispielsweise oder die
arbeit und dann haben wir dann irgendwie
zweck zu nehmen würden oder so dann wäre
es vielleicht ein bisschen blöd werden
die sache noch nicht dafür geupdatet
sind dann hängen hier nämlich irgendwie
zweck sind 64 pixeln und das normale
tech schmeckt dann 16 pixum dass wir
nicht so cool und noch eine sache
und zwar wird uns auch geschrieben dass
wir eine kuh getötet haben
du hast die kugel tödlich und weise
verboten
sollten die eigentlich gar nicht wissen
weil wir die irgendwie noch für später
brauchen können wir uns eventuell mal in
den kommentaren darüber unterhalten so
mehr oder weniger das jetzt schlimm war
oder ob jetzt gar nicht mehr
weiterkommen da irgendwie so und komme
sagt immer wie wir das jetzt mit den
zuschauerfragen machen wollen damit ihr
auch nicht sofort kommt mit einem
zuschauer fragen wie wollen wir das
sommer machen wollen wir haben gesagt
doch das wäre es über twitter machen
wollen oder will ich jetzt richtig genau
wir haben am anfang gesagt dass wir
jetzt über twitter machen genauer also
wir wollen natürlich wieder damit wir
auch so ein paar themen mal wieder haben
wir bei epic jim webb und bei anderen
wollen wir gemeinsam was machen und um
halt hier so wenig die stillen fast
manchmal zu füllen man wert auf themen
von euch eingehen auf eure fragen themen
was auch immer und die könnt ihr euch
uns einfach stellen auf twitter unter
dem hashtag den crafter heraus
hierzu hätte das nächste da nicht sauber
nicht etwas zu essen
ich hab doch hier immer verboten fleisch
geil geil
bei mir hängt immer so jederzeit der
fremde ein bisschen aber es liegt
einfach daran dass mein pc zwei wochen
nicht an wand da muss ich erst mal
wieder warm laufen genau dahinter ist
einfach so eine chance hätte man lieber
voran
ja ich habe ja ich muss erstmal wieder
leben generieren so ein bisschen ich hab
mir us bogen so geil ich meist immer
noch pfeile hin
ja so was auf gesamt siehst du krasse
perfekt ok kinder und habe ich etwas
bekommen von ihr ja wohl unter welchem
hersteller das denn obwohl wir das
vielleicht mal jemand über oder über
youtube kommentare machen über youtube
kommentare könnten wir auch machen
ich weiß nicht dass wir das wieder
werden ideen twitter ist ja nicht jeder
richtig ja gut dann machen wir immer was
anderes wenn jemand einfach über youtube
kommentare schreibt gegen den kassen als
test machen einfach mal die kuh sitzt
immer noch in diesem produkt einfach vor
jeder folge die themen raus die wir dann
bei twitter ist es nämlich immer so
gewesen dass man da quasi einfach sagen
kann
ok com schreibt uns jetzt themen und
dann ist man live während der aufnahme
mit in twitter drin und dann kommt
wieder live dabei im youtube kommentaren
ist das halt so da kann man die
achterbahn während ihr das quasi
schreibt deswegen ja wir können einfach
mal schauen
ich habe das einfach mal themen youtube
kommentaren blender coole weisen dann
können uns die ja so abfotografiert
screenshot
und richtig und dann wieder in der von
brennet genauer darauf ein oder auch
richtig also ich wahrscheinlich gar
nicht wusste ich ich auch ich habe da
ich auch keine lust auf eine zügige
lesen das natürlich dann vor den
kommentar aber beantworten
hast du reisen ich habe eisen ich weiß
aber noch nicht eigentlich am 17
17 eisen und 14 gold bisher so ein
geiler hengst er ja da aber muss auch
alles geschmolzen werden
ja weil ich habe nicht gedacht dass wir
uns mal reisen spitzhacke machen weil
ich ja meine verloren habe naja
explosion da und weil du mich da auch
getötet hass und
aber du bist gar nicht hören quatsch ich
doch nicht aber er alles ich war total
brass effekt heraus ich hab dich
getötete leben ja noch nicht getötet ich
habe nichts gefühlt ich töte ich muss
mich ja nochmal rechnen oder ich bin ne
na.de hast du gemacht hast mich dann das
loch hinunter geschubst wurde
monster drin waren ja habe ich guck dir
von meiner heutigen vorjahr spring halte
ich für ein gerücht ich glaube ich das
gemacht habe und ich würde vorschlagen
du machst heute nochmal hier die
challenge mit den ohren ist der lore in
meiner jungen wächst einfach mal so ein
baum in mir drin
richtiges arschloch oman ist das gerne
auf video grande gehabt ja ich stehe
einfach sobald ich mach mir mal ganz
kurz eine schaufel und eine axt und dann
geht man da nach dauer und baut das gold
noch ab wir ja eine reise die ich mir
gerade gemacht habe ich würde sagen
lassen die tierchen erstmalig am leben
wir haben hier schon wirklich ein
kleines zu runde das bild ist aber dass
er halt nur eine kuh haben können wir
nicht ein comic-buch
wir erweitern der unseren hoffentlich
kommt doch ne kuh oder können irgendwie
auch ne kuh anderer an staaten wollen
ich höre auf die ganz fetten monster wie
war jetzt erstmal ab was die zuschauer
sagen und wenn da geschrieben wird ja
könnt gar nicht mehr gewinn hier bei
dieser kasse und gar nicht mehr weiter
gar nicht komplett verloren dann müssen
wir wirklich schauen dass wir plan b und
sono ich an kanten texture pack drin
neues level is the prospects drin
ich habe mich hatten als labil sind
jetzt einfach abgeschossen und das geht
auch also ich überlege naja muss man mal
schauen sie zwecks muss man schauen
wegen den blöcken der die junge design
gelegt ist ja so krass hat immer
richtung sich vom munter wenn ich habe
schon geschafft aber das hat sich
einfach so hinter einem blog versteckte
mich die ganze zeit abgeschlossen ich
dachte unten kann nichts mehr
ebenso viele zombies immer noch es
könnte auch sein dass die aus diesen
anderen höhlen gängen kommen die wir
quasi sich ausleuchten können weil wir
da noch nicht hin können weißt du ich
höre auch so komische sounds und ich
weiß einfach gar nicht was damit vor
und hier sind so viele fledermäuse du
willst du denn dass ich egal beim
feldherrn bekommt co.com kräfte bei
diesen los mit dem du hast das gold hier
unten schon abgebaut
er habe ich gemacht natürlich ich habe
nie gekriegt mit der spitzhacke abruft
ich dachte wir hätten also spitzer
gemälde aus wald aufhalten
ach so du hattest einen starken hier
sind alle ärzte wirklich noch einen
weiteren weg kommen
der pharma ich mache gerade das feld
fertig das ist super da wurde ich auch
einen kommentar geschrieben dass wir das
licht für brauchen vier stationären
gestellt na ja das habe ich schon dass
ich schon gemacht
gute live ich bin direkt wieder gekommen
aus dem urlaub direkt kommentare gelesen
dann war natürlich scheiße auf eltern
begrüßt und alles quatsch übrigens wir
sind ja mit bulgarien er geflogen
der fiat kommen nicht vor der aufnahme
schon total ausklappt für so ein paar
dinge soweit okay also bevor kontrakt
danach bulgarien geflogen ist habe ich
in einem tag davor also bei unserer
letzten aufnahme noch so gesagt pass auf
wenn du in bulgarien am strand hängen
wie da gibt's die pinkel mafia-boss auf
den punkt zu bringen
die schnell mal ganz böse wird und
sobald wir genauer berichten muss was da
jetzt aber gibt es noch gewarnt
die pilz mafia ist halt erstmal die gibt
es wirklich das ist witzig witzig oder
so das heißt man wird sich an aber es
ist wirklich so ernst
das ist wie wenn du nachts in
deutschland irgendwo hingeht und ins
gebüsch pinkls an fast jeden tag machst
du hast du hast jetzt fehlt nee das geht
nicht heraus weil ich habe auch schon
brot gemacht
doch hatte erfolg ach so ja du hast den
erfolg aber es bringt uns nichts für die
world border slava wir können uns lava
holen naja einem jedenfalls gibt es die
fis mafia um das mal von dieser folge
jetzt hoffentlich zu ende zu bringen und
diese bis mafia ist nicht so was wie
dass da so ganz viele leute in wie man
sich ja vorstellen smoking rumlaufen und
böse sind und die italiener und kanada
sowie griffen alle möglichen sondern das
sind halt wirklich einfach irgendwelche
bulgaren die da am strand und in den
büschen hocken und warten bis da
irgendwelche also ich wir waren halt
wirklich goldstrand das kann ich einfach
mal so sagen das ist das ist golden
sands oder auf englisch hallo und ich
gehe wieder nach oben das da ist halt
wirklich eine party statt da sind 80
einfach wirklich deutsch also sowie auf
malta und die wissen halt so wenn man
die besoffen sind dann gehen die
irgendwohin und pissen einfach
irgendwohin postbank noch gar nichts
passiert
hier sind so viele monster grad gewesen
ja gut jedenfalls die schnappen sich
dann wenn die dichter pinkeln gehen und
sagen hey was angepinkelt gebt uns geld
das ist nicht vom staat irgendwie
abgesichert oder sowie die polizei die
dann sagen würde ja entweder hier außer
ist das und das und so blabla sondern
wenn du denen dann sagst du dir ich gebe
ihnen kein geld an toxin direkt aufs
maul und naja also mir ist es nicht
passiert dann
da da kommen mir das gesagt hat sich das
echt pausenlos wohin gepinkelt
aber die ein paar freunde von mir ich
hab das halt nur ein paar gesagt mit
partnern hat einfach nichts zu tun die
da mitfahren
die sind echt mit den in kontakt
gekommen und habe ihn an geld gegeben
das hat dann irgendwie zähler gekostet
also levers diese wäre gar das
unternehmen fünf euro oder so und weil
das die sache bald ein anderer kumpel
von mir da erwischt wurde
er hat gedacht okay kein topteam
auszugeben dann einfach zu diesem thema
für typen gesagt hey logo war der unter
der wäsche gucken dann ist er halt weg
gelaufen vor dem und er hat auch echt
geschafft und es war halt echt schon
mega krass weil
ein anderer kam mit einem blauen auge
nach hause und meinte so ein komma die
prisma verkam das ist schon sehr sehr
krass gewesen
und was ich jetzt auch noch sagen wollte
mit bulgarien er dass wir sind mit
bulgarien er geflogen
und das hat alle zwei minuten auf dem
hinweg kam einfach so eine meldung
wir haben turbulenzen bitte anschnallen
und immer das flugzeug sind voller
wackeln das war genauso wie als wenn
diese träger diese flugzeugträger oder
als träger flügel keine ahnung sahen so
aus als wenn ich zusammen genäht gewesen
mit zu tackern zusammen getackert sonne
scheiß qualität hatte diese bulgarien er
diese flugzeuge existieren seit 27
jahren fliegen seit 27 jahren und sind
schon auf mehreren internationalen
flughäfen nicht mehr zugelassen weil sie
eine schlechte qualität habe und wir
sind nach bulgarien geflogen und es war
so krass ich kann so froh sein dass ich
noch lebe
das war so toll einfach nicht so gefreut
hat sich auf deutschem boden war da so
also meine berge meine programme drei
sind drei worten beschreiben müsste
würde ich sagen
strafen zahlen also alle strafen weil
man da muss man für alle strafen
bezahlen
das war so krass ich heb den klodeckel
unserem hotel an
und der ist einfach abgebrochen 10 leber
strafe sogar gesagt wir machen unseren
schrank auf die schranktür halte hält
auf einmal mein kumpel in der hand auch
wieder strafe jemanden der eine kriegt
einfach auf die fresse der landkreis und
vor allem jetzt die die die krasseste
sache da war so ein halber amoklauf
hotel ankam
doch das war so heftig wie war damit
abendessen um 19 uhr da so billiges
wetter da war überall musik und so und
sind an das hotel gegangen und also in
diesen innenhof und dann in dem innenhof
kann man auf einmal so richtig großer
stärker pigmentierter mann an und
hatte nur badelatschen an und eine weiße
jogginghose und einfach sein sakko
einfach so ein schwarzes sakko und
darunter fand nichts an
und wir dachten schon zu erlassen das
viel spaß die das bilde hier
dann legte er sein schwarzes handy auf
den tisch dann noch alle schwein da noch
sein sondern so ein schwarzes
portemonnaie und einfach eine software
und in dem moment auch talente klare
wäre oder dann der torkelte mit seiner
mit seiner software halt in der hand und
noch lebt hier auf einmal so nach und
dann alle so ein paar mädchen laufen
schon so weg zu security und so wir
sitzen da so wir waren halt echt noch
relativ gut da wäre ich kein bock hatten
aufzustellen weil er war viel zu voll da
hätte kein getroffen oder so aber wir
hatten halt schon so auf fachmann was
soll wir machen
aber wenn du dann weg glaubt natürlich
im moment an man hat halt etwas total
dieser shop angst und der typ wird man
einfach seine waffe viel zu oft so
kleine mädchen und so was alles als viel
zu wichtig weil diese neuigkeit hat in
der kamera doch wirklich wirklich ich
hab davon kein foto aber das war so
krass das war ich ich ich würde auf
alles was ich besitze dieser typ
gedachten erwägt eine echte waffe
gezielt auf leute und drückt dann auch
so tun aber das halten und software
deswegen geld gemacht hotelbesitzer denn
das modell besitzt aber obwohl sowie das
hotel aus aber das locker der
hotelbesitzer
das ist kein ende das ist ja ganz schön
finde ich auch cool wenn wir das spiel
machen würde und dann junge der dieb
wird erzählt auch so mädchen diese
mädchen rennen so schreien weg die
kreisschau so rum
ich dachte echt in dem moment ist ein
amoklauf ich mein kumpel die da gegessen
haben waren schon kurz davor ihr wohin
zu laufen durch die botanik durch und
einfach unter weitesten suchen und da
kann man was sie tun hat denn somit
geführt dass dieser typ des ticketing
software gefahr
er kam noch so ein polizist an und hat
ja die an den mann abgeführt weil das
war echt so krass
das war zwar nur eine softgun softer
aber dass die hätte uns halt keinen
schaden zugefügt aber einfach dieser
moment das man so weit dass der quasi
eine klare zurück das ist so krass ich
hatte noch nie so ein komisches gefühl
in meinem leben und du weißt ja echt gar
nicht okay ist das eine echte oder was
macht er jetzt und vor allem noch mal an
sache ein anderer kumpel von mir der
waldmann sie dazu hier
der war im hotel unterwegs und hat
einfach so ein paar russen so hallo
gesagt und naja ich weiß nicht was also
nichts gegen russen licht gehabt viele
russische freunde aber die waren
irgendwie nicht so cool drauf haben wir
doch einfach auf morgen boxwelt jetzt im
doppelten kieferbruch
der ist den ganzen urlaub nur noch mit
seiner band am kopf herum gelaufen also
wenn ich brutal beschreiben müsste würde
ich sagen aggressiv dass es so krass wie
es da abgeht also das ist echt zu heftig
mir ist nichts passiert zum glück dann
komme der mich da vor allen gefahren
gewarnt
jaja da ging ich ihn gut kannte ich
schon direkt via voraussehen okay hakan
crafter musste aufpassen da habe ich
auch gemacht wird in rathenow dem
flothkötter konnte ich nicht vor waren
einfach alles aus jeder gebrauchen was
angefasst hast ja so krass wie mutig und
nicht ganz sauber ja gut wenn doch die
im wasser und bh keine ahnung wo ja gut
dann habe das ganze jetzt mal ein
bisschen schöner gemacht weil es war
echt ein rumpelstilzchen wir uns dann
wieder den erfolgen hier so ein bisschen
was machen
applaus für die geschichte echt liefern
dankbar war spannender auf jeden fall
zuzuhören ich wünschte ich hätte ein
foto gemacht
na ja ich würde sagen wir haben uns von
diesem gibt angeblichen urteil besitzer
mit der software genau es steht also die
meistens foto letzte first state selfio
killer gewesen
ja ja ja gut ich würde sagen wir werden
die folge und die nächste folge ist bei
komme wenn es euch gefallen hat also
morgen dann wenn es euch gefallen aber
zeigt sich bewährt und ich laufe jetzt
immer ganz kurz nach oben und dann
vielleicht war ja schon mal einer von
euch die bulgarin könnte es mir meine
kommentare schreiben was eure erlebnisse
so war jetzt schreibe so also ja ich war
dieser typ mit der software
na ja gut wir sehen uns morgen bei komme
wieder mit